Speaker 1: Let's go to Mica from Idaho.
Mica from Idaho, not a heavily represented
state among live callers. Welcome, Mica.
Speaker 2: Hello. Thank you. So I had
two quick questions, if that's okay.
But first, I wanted to see how your
new Year was. Did you do anything fun or.
Speaker 1: I had a I had dinner with some
friends and my baby daughter completely
lost it. And that was basically it. Yeah.
Speaker 2: Are doing.
Speaker 1: Well. But the
good news was the followed.
Speaker 2: Was.
Speaker 1: Another kid sneezed directly into
my daughter's face and my daughter didn't get
sick. So I consider that a win.
Speaker 3: That is when my.
Speaker 2: My dogs sneeze on my
face basically every morning.
It's. It's fantastic.
Speaker 1: Your dog's.
Speaker 2: Highly recommended. Yes.
Speaker 1: We can. Humans get, like,
stuff from dogs they can't write.
Speaker 3: Other than.
Speaker 1: Rabies.
Speaker 2: Things like COVID.
And there are a couple of, like, parasites that
they can carry that dogs or that humans can get
to. But for the most part, like parvo
and like the things that they typically
deal with, they're more specifically dogs.
Speaker 1: All right. Well, good. Not good for
the dogs. Good for the humans, I guess.
Speaker 2: Sure.
Speaker 1: But what's on your mind?
Speaker 2: Well, we're going to see,
so. Yet. A caller mentioned the stunts with
sending the migrants to two different places where
they're not going like Kamala Harris's house.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Kamala. Kamala.
Speaker 2: Come on. Come on. Okay. I was
just wondering. So, like, I don't really.
See any political gain for anyone in that
situation. I have a hard time seeing what the
right wing would see as desirable in that, because
you help me understand what's going on there.
Speaker 1: So here's what you need to
understand to understand why Republicans
think that that's a good idea. Okay. Republicans
have this ideology, I guess we would call it,
which we sometimes call strict father morality,
which means that people should suffer the
consequences of their actions. If you have sexual
relations outside of marriage, you should have to
suffer the consequences of getting pregnant and
carrying the child to term. You can't get a get
out of jail free card like birth control
or the morning after pill or an abortion,
even if those are solutions that there's no real
reason to prevent being available to people. And
similarly, Republicans believe and Micah, you have
to get into the mind of the Republican Republicans
believe that it is Democrats and not Republicans,
Democrats in blue states that are saying open
the border, let everybody in, no control at all.
Even though Democrats aren't saying these things,
this is the story Republicans tell themselves. So
Republicans believe if Democrats in blue states
are going to be the one letting everybody in, the
immigrants should be sent to the blue states to
make those blue states deal with the consequences
of letting everybody in. It's all made up,
Mike. Don't get me wrong, but that's the internal
logic that they apply to it. That's why they
think it's a great thing to send the migrants to
Martha's Vineyard and D.C. from Texas and Florida.
Speaker 2: Okay. Thank you.
That makes a little more sense.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, it makes no sense,
but hopefully what they are thinking now,
you understand? Which is insane.
Speaker 2: Yes, that is correct.
Speaker 1: All right. All right,
Micah, thank you. Appreciate the call.
Speaker 2: Okay. Thanks. All right.
Speaker 1: There is Micah from Idaho
with with a great question, quite frankly.